- Peng Shuai, attablée avec deue
discussion avec son entraîneur.
La vidéo a été piteur en chef
du Global Times, un média proche
du régime chinois.
Sur une deuxième vidéo, on voit
l'athlète de taurant, qui se trt
à Pékin. Impossible de certifier
les enregistrements, mais
dans la fenêtre, une affiche
sur lainscriinscriinscriinscrii:
20 novembre 2021.
Même si les vidéos s'avéraient
bel et bien authentiques,
ce ser
insuffisantes pour s'assurerète.
GUY ST-JACQUES, ancien
ambassadeur du Canada en Ca proé
que tout ça a été orchestré,qu'o
et qu'on lui a demandé
de jouer un jeu.sadeur du Canada
en Chine estime que Peng Shuai
doit faire l'objet de menaces
sérieuses de la part
du régime chinoiuiétude grandit
autour du sort de l'athlète
depuis sa disparition
il y a plus de deux semaines.
L'anci
ble a disparu après avoir
accusé sur Internet Zhang Gaoli,
un puissant ex-responsable
d'agression sexuelle.
s, des photos d'elle
qui n'ont pas été authentifiées
non plus ont été publiées
officiellement bloqué en Chine.t
de son sort, comme la WTA, qui
régit le tennis féminin mondial,
ces preuves sont douteuses.
une nouvelle fois exprimé après
la publication des vidéos.
- J'espère que les pays
sur l'occasion pour demander des
chinois.
la vague d'indignation sur
le web de la part de joueu
tennis notamment n'empêchera pas
à elle seule la Chine de se Ici,
Radio-Canada, M